لم توقف هذه الفيضانات التي اجتاحت جنوب
شرقي اوكرانيا جراء انهيار سد نوفا لم
توقف القتال المستعر فيها حتى انه تصاعد
في شرقها تزامنا مع بدء الهجوم الاوكراني
المضاد وزاره الدفاع البريطانيه تقول ان
المعارك العنيفه مستمره على جبهه القتال
مع تاكيدهم ان كيف تمتلك المبادره وزير
الدفاع الروسي سيرجي شايغو بين ان قوات
بلاده صدت هجوما اوكرانيا ليلا جنوبيه
شارك فيه 1500 جندي اضافه الى 150 عربه
مدرعه مع محاولات اوكرانيه لاختراق الخطوط
الروسيه
المعارك استمرت ايضا حول فيليكا نوفو
سيلكا التابعه لدوناتسك الواقعه شرقا
ويعتقد محللون ان المنطقه ستشكلان خط
المواجهه المستقبلي
اما باخموت التي شهدت واحده من اطول
المعارك واكثرها دمويه في الحرب فان
القوات الاوكرانيه تتقدم فيها ضد نظيرتها
الروسيه
تطورات عسكريه ترسم خط الهجوم المضاد
الاوكراني الا ان محللين يربطون نجاحه
بتوفير طائرات مقاتله قادره على توفير
الدعم الجوي
وبانهاءه خلال خمسه اشهر قبل بدء موسم
الامطار الخريفيه التي تجعل الارض
المفتوحه غير سالكه للمركبات المدرعه
الثقيله ويقاس نجاح الهجوم المضاد بالتمكن
القوات الاوكرانيه من اختراق الخطوط
الروسيه على طول الطريق الى بحر ازوف فاي
قوات روسيه غربيه لاختراق ستكون اكثر عرضه
للخطر وكل ما سيبقى بعد ذلك هو تدمير جسر
القرم الذي يعتقد ان روسيا ستعتمد عليه
لخطوط الامداد ومن ثم مهاجمه السفن
والطائرات المستخدمه لعرقله الامدادات الى
شبه الجزيره
سيناريو ان حدث سيونهي الحرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيه بحسب محللين الا انه لن يحدث
برايهم في القريب العاجل رش خياط العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات